comment une fausse rumeur de la première
guerre mondiale aux nuits en la croyance
de l'holocauste pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
[Musique]
alors nous sommes en 1917 en plein coeur
de la première guerre mondiale le
conflit s'enlise coûte cher en vie coûte
cher en matériaux coûtent cher ou sans
équipement militaire et la
grande-bretagne aimerait bien que la
chine se joignent aux alliés afin de
mettre un terme à ce conflit
et pour y parvenir on va utiliser une
fausse rumeur qui existe en fait depuis
assez longtemps dans la campagne
française cette idée qu'on utilise des
cadavres humains pour faire la margarine
société la rumeur populaire ou faire du
suif à une époque où il ya des blocs
commerciaux et on cherche de nouveaux
moyens de nouveaux procédés pour pouvoir
faire du suivre pour faire de la
glycérine aussi alors les services
secrets britanniques vont utiliser cette
rumeur qui plane depuis le début de la
première guerre mondiale
ils vont diffuser l'information au
gouvernement chinois et ça va henri fier
le gouvernement chinois un point tel
qu'ils vont décider de se joindre à la
première guerre mondiale
on va utiliser aussi des photographies
qui ont été prises deux convois
allemands et pour les services secrets
britanniques on va dire que c'est la
preuve qu'on a des convois de cadavres
humains qui sont envoyés vers des usines
qui vont produire du suif
c'est comme ça que naît aussi la grande
clameur populaire du sinn à cadavres
chez les allemands pendant la première
guerre mondiale
alors cette rumeur a eu des conséquences
dramatiques puisque lorsque les
britanniques vont commencer à une autre
idée qu hitler est en train de tuer des
juifs donc le low cost littéralement ça
va être long en fait avant que les
paysages y croit à cette théorie puisque
on savait qu'on avait utilisé une fausse
rumeur pendant la première guerre
mondiale en 925 effectivement les
services secrets britanniques avait
admis avoir manipulé l'information pour
convaincre le gouvernement chinois de se
joindre aux conflits et du côté de new
york vous avez un convoi un député
conservateur aussi du nom de john
tractoriste va vraiment parler de la
supercherie et de l'objectif vraiment
très très clair qui était d'amener la
chine à se joindre aux britanniques afin
de mettre un terme à la menace allemande